thank you
[Music]
welcome back to a very special careful
boys we're very careful boys and today
we're talking about what do you do to
improve your bad mood
your bad mood boy or girl I improve it
by being even more batter moods oh yeah
I go for a walk
take a shower just I try to like change
my physical state that's always good
workout
that's a good one working out is a good
one yeah it's a really good one or
punching something that usually helps a
little bit but then you get mad again
because you're like oh now my hand hurts
and I'm [__] pissed I don't ruminate
and linger anymore really you moved on
from that show it's hard to stay like I
would rage for like I could stay on the
[__] thought for like a whole week
and then that's exhausting
if you're pissed yeah I'll go to sleep
[__] mad and then I wake up still mad
and then like I would I I'd be able to
like think of all the different ways of
how I'm gonna get revenge and everything
and then now I'm just like
okay uh it's a lot of work
[Laughter]
you're just too busy it hurts me being
too busy helps us and then yeah I just
go
um you know the soft serve machine's
broken I should probably deal with that
and then I go to sleep yeah worst thing
to worry about yeah but back then I
wouldn't be even be able to think about
oh the this is malfunctioning I gotta go
fix this and then I gotta fix that
because everything that's on my mind is
like oh this [__] wrong me I'm gonna
get them back or what whatever whatever
was on my mind you know
that that was a difficult thing and I
don't really know what changed I don't I
never made a conscious effort all I know
is that now I'm much better at um being
aware of what I'm speaking in my head is
it because you're busier
I think uh
one thing that I know that I did get
better at and this probably has
something to do with it but
uh several years ago I realized that um
I would I would wake up in panic attacks
oh that's damn that's big that's tough
and then um
I didn't realize that I was doing that
throughout my whole life
where I would just wake up in panic and
I just go back to sleep but Hannah kind
of I recognized it there because then
she was like oh you just woke up and
you're like scared or something I'm like
what
so you know you go back to sleep you
don't remember and whatever wow
so there'll be moments where like I wake
up and I'm just my heart is racing and
then I'm just thinking
I'm not think I'm not thinking I'm half
asleep so I get up and then I'm just
like oh [__] and then you just have a
groggy day right and I don't know what
happened or whatever and then when I
processed that then I was more aware
half asleep I would wake up and I'd be
like okay I'm thinking about things I'm
scared of things in the past that hurt
me like all these weird
intrusive thoughts or whatever that's
just sneaking through my head right and
that's what's scary because I feel
vulnerable I'm like in a sleeping
position and then while I'm half asleep
I can calm myself down
and that made me much better at uh being
aware of what kind of uh conversations I
was having in my head throughout the day
um and then before that it was pure
impulse everything was just whatever was
happening in the moment was whatever was
happening that's affecting you the most
yeah and then uh now I don't really have
like those things where I wake up and
like my heart's racing good job dude
yeah and if I do feel it coming like if
I wake up like I'm thinking about it in
my head and I go oh it's happening just
it's not real like relax
and then I just take a few breaths and I
go right back to sleep so then that was
a huge thing I think just being aware of
what I'm thinking of was a big big
changer and just everything it applied
to everything else so like so what
advice would you give somebody who's
having issues pushing their intrusive
thoughts out of the way who who can't
just like take a few breaths and they're
not at that stage yet like what would
you tell them to do practice
um what so not everyone speaks in their
own head is what I realize too some
people see and they they see pictures in
their head or they just don't even say
words that's what I realized but for me
I talk in my head a lot right and
there's different conversations
different versions of me and dinosaur
battles dinosaur battles cool stingrays
whatever yeah uh and I think um
try to bring up the voice of like a calm
reasonable human being you have that
thought too and let that one win or like
you know like like uh it's not that what
do you call it it's whatever's happening
in the moment it's not that serious it
never is but then it it is in the moment
because you're having an emotional
reaction yeah so intrusive Dinosaur cool
calm collected dinosaur yeah they're
fighting and then the fact that you're
thinking about these two metaphorical
dinosaurs fighting is the fact that you
can call yourself okay cool there it is
welcome to male mind yeah that's my mind
those were my favorite lines by the way
the last couple months yeah
how guys think and sometimes girls think
their body language exercise so Joe's
like I'm just having a dinosaur battle
in my head
that's so true it's so true dude
nothing about anything yeah I have that
too girls zone out too I believe it but
but when we get accused what were you
just thinking about babe and we're like
oh you don't want to know I'm being
insecure right yeah you might even have
to make things up because then they
bother you so much yes would you say I
go are you mad at me she's like yes I've
been trying to find ways it's pretty
good that's all that's why I calm down
the situation
internal dialogue if I could simplify
because that's all it is the internal
dialogue and nothing's like too extreme
you you suffer like what what that quote
you suffer more in imagination than you
do in reality so true yeah that's what I
do sometimes I usually think of a more
severe situation like my mom was
tripping this morning just talking about
something like my mom's like uh she's
like she's trying to evict one of the
tenants in her or whatever but she's
like I think she has to do it by this
imaginary deadline and then she's like
[__] tripping on the phone I'm like
is someone gonna come and cut your hands
off and she was like read this question
I was like if I was like okay let's say
you prolong it for seven days someone
gonna [__] come and cut your hands
off she's like no well then shut the
[__] up
but I actually helped my mom out she's
like yeah that's right because like I
think a lot of times it probably sounds
way better in Chinese too yeah because I
think like a lot of times like whatever
you're experiencing it does feel like
life or death
and so it helps me out when I think of
something more severe then it kind of
like puts what I'm thinking and feeling
into perspective and I'm like
that's just this yeah just that that's
why I resort to working out because it's
like now you're physically doing
something where your mind's now focused
on what you're physically doing you're
benefiting from them benefiting from
like the dopamine
a calmer effect on um those intrusive
thoughts
um I weight lift but it depends on like
the day what's your favorite lift bruh
um I like deadlift title yeah that's a
good way to get it's a bench now too
because I think like
like especially for women
um
too much because it looks weird yeah I
can only bench the like bar maybe to 10
pound weights I'm out
Somebody's gotta save me from 65 pounds
I like the phrase
um control the controllable too because
a lot of time like you know when you
have like you're in a bad mood and
you're like kind of like stuck on
something you can't really control how
you feel yeah but you can control what
you're doing in the moment so if you're
like on the couch or wherever in the car
and that whole environment is making me
feel like something then go work out go
do something or maybe go grab a snack or
even call up a friend just to talk yeah
like what are the things that you can
control and usually if you go in that
direction and build some sort of
positive momentum you'll feel better in
like 20 30 minutes and you're not stuck
there anymore yeah that's my favorite
thing to do is like uh
my my go-to is to find the humor in it
because I think it's always possible
yeah but if I can't in the moment
because it's so fresh I try to think of
a something that happened that's worse
than this and remember that I do see the
humor in that yeah oh yeah it eventually
happens but if I can't do it I all I do
is just simply hang out with a person
that I like that has nothing to do with
the thing I'm upset about and I
immediately I immediately can't think of
it I'm just like then I just enjoy this
person and I enjoy the time and it's
like it's great I think getting out of
your head is super important super
important yeah you're just gonna repeat
whatever's bothering you and then that
boils up yeah or if you're in an
argument and if you're in a situation
where you're both not like you're kind
of getting crazier and crazier like it's
gonna erupt somewhere and and someone's
got to stop it or else it's gonna be
like violence or something sometimes I
like fighting the humor in myself in the
moment yes like I'm like zooming out of
yourself
am I [__] tripping over this yeah
yeah yeah I'm like dude this is so it's
like almost like you know when you look
at yourself when you're like in your
teens and you're like sipping for love
and you're doing all the dumbest [__]
possible it's like the same thing like
you kind of like look at yourself in
third person you're like oh my God I
can't like [__] trip over this thing
it's like [__] nothing and then you
find like the humor in that too and that
helps out too yeah I think what helped
me was to realize like um all of these
things happen when you're the most
vulnerable right so like when you're the
most tired and you're not there mentally
because like it's easier when you're
well rested you're sharp and then you're
not emotionally aroused so like
so like when you're not yourself or like
triggered in some different way and then
you might be attacking someone because
of let's say like a past thing right
like let's say somebody bullied you and
something remembers and then
subconsciously your guards go up and
you're starting to feel like violent
towards someone
it's like you gotta remember that all
these things
pop up in the times when you least can
deal with it and then so when you can
realize that I think that helps a lot
because it's it always goes down when
you're like you already did it well at
least for me you already did the day
that you kind of
um what do you call it like you already
acted out in the way that you regretted
because you were unaware and you were
impulsive yeah so then you're impulsive
because you don't you lack self-control
during those moments so how do you stay
aware in those moments of time when
you're at this emotional state and
you're like an absolute animal and
you're not even thinking clearly a temp
perspective like Bart does that's really
smart so how do you snap out of that
animal having the sense of humor inside
of yourself to zoom out of yourself and
laugh at how funny something is is
pretty good like I've done that many
times I think it's one of my go-to's for
sure another thing that I do is actually
a weird meditation that I've always done
since I was like a little kid I've done
this before I've actually done it
actually like on me and Iggy's podcast
[__] they don't tell you I've actually
done it like I just like take you
through exactly wow yeah and I love it
that [__] is so important I [__] love
it like I like zoom out of my body I
zoom I visualize where I'm at visualize
like
above myself and where I'm at and I go
above that above that and above that and
I go all the way out and there's this
beautiful thing I swear to God it's like
the coolest thing ever if you can
actually like face the stars all I mean
by that you're like fly outside of all
of this [__] you get outside like the
planet and [__] you see earth like this
small Earth you look in it or no no
you're looking at Earth it's real big
and [__] but then you turn around the
turnaround's the most powerful thing in
the [__] world
you turn around and you feel the light
of the universe the warmth the energy
all the all the light of the universe is
coming to one place [__] it's coming
to us right and if you can feel that
that love like that like warm blanket it
is like nothing else you'll ever
experience and I can get there real
quick because I've been doing it since I
was a kid oh that's awesome yeah yeah
and I I uh it's my little life hack
because like even my mom always said
when I was growing up like she's always
like you're my light and [__] and then
like Nikki whenever she's freaking the
[__] out about something like I I keep
Center pretty quick and like get to the
rational part of things pretty quick
because I could focus Steve is the
Teletubby son dude you're gonna have to
have Warren Bell do you ever go there
when it's like let's say you have crazy
turbulence in the airplane do you go
there too or
I don't need to uh no because I because
oh dude I was just on an airplane with
crazy triples there's a guy next to me
he was like [__] freaking out wide
stance in this [__] yeah
he was white knuckling the armrest so
I'm not even kidding he was like [__]
funny poor guy poor guy I know but but
no I um I don't know it's one of those
things where I have a very Kismet
attitude about things like where if it
was my time to go I know it is you're
just like [__] it yeah what are you
gonna do in a moment what are you gonna
do what are you gonna do with your
control so you might as well try to
control what you can do a cockpit dude
the last moment
it's cocky as [__] and it's
disrespectful I think to the powers that
be to think that you are in control yeah
you gotta bust that door down dude you
gotta wait for the oxygen mask to come
down yeah no but it's not about you
anymore it's about that's everything
yeah you know what else you'd be doing
since you were a kid jerking it poop but
I think a poop
the first step to pivoting is
recognition because like I I think most
people
um you know they haven't removed or saw
their ego yet so what ends up happening
is the first thing you do is blame yeah
so like that's the go-to in most
people's minds even and it's way more
comforting to do that in the moment for
a lot of people it's easier yeah you go
to a defensive place like right away
it's everyone else's fault it's not mine
yeah yeah and most people live this way
right so then they could never create
the coping skills or just like how to
deal with whatever because they don't
have to deal with it it's their fault
they made me mad they did this to me so
then
if you can't recognize that all these
feelings and pains and things are
happening within you and you can control
that narrative then it I think that's
the first step when is everybody else's
fault you just give your power away yeah
so just like no no you can't do anything
no control there goes your control are
you a baby that's why that's why I tell
myself are you a [__] small child is
this why you have to lash out and like
are you not 30 years old and you have to
be an adult and deal with your problems
I tell that to myself I talk [__] to
myself yeah that scale is dangerous
though because on the other flip side
you have people that blame the [__] out
of themselves excessively and then next
thing you know they [__] kill
themselves oh you know what it is though
too is like you have to
at least for me what works for me is
like I just tell myself that it's like
so not about you in a lot of ways like
it like I think a lot of us are really
self-absorbed of like how we think of
are problems and it's like what was me
all the time I think that is like a easy
trap to fall in but when you like what
what you guys were all saying in
different ways like pulling out and
zooming out and realizing that it's like
okay
what's bother I try to ask myself a ton
of questions of like what's bothering me
why is it bothering me is it something I
can control or is it something that
I can't control and then from there
depending on what that answer is then I
can move forward or not move forward
right or just kind of sit in it and just
be like okay I'm upset it's not gonna be
the last problem you're gonna have yeah
exactly
I'll get used to it my favorite thing is
arriving to the statement no one [__]
cares exactly exactly exactly it's not
it's not that serious
other Steve next to you and he's like I
care I don't care and you start crying
I've never tried this before I feel like
my work good if like let's say you feel
like [__] about something
give yourself a beat and try to
Freestyle and rhyme that what you're
feeling so definitely laugh at yourself
yeah like right away you probably
started laughing give me a beat
and he trying to Freestyle right away
and try to rhyme that word as many times
as you can you go to an open mic I'm
ready I just write poetry dude that's
what I do [__] dude and I get my
emotions out all right you know one
thing that helps me when I'm like in a
in that state of mind whether it's like
anger or fear or whatever is to start
solving the thing that I'm worried about
yeah but women hate that
yeah yeah
for myself
you know yeah women having problems if
it's a soul if it's a solo campaign
that's good
that's a bad move [__] off with that
trust me
but I think like there's some feeling of
it's like ASMR or relief when you're
taking actionable steps towards
something
um when I talk about it and do nothing
it actually makes it worse for me yeah
like that's what anxiety is asking me I
repeat the same story I'm reliving the
uncertainty I'm getting more and more
worried but then if I just shut all that
out and I start solving it and then all
the conversations that I have is like
people giving me advice on like how to
fix or maybe look at it at a different
angle then like I see progress of things
happening then I feel relief yeah
[Music]
foreign